hey guys so it's been seven months since
i got my
macbook air m1 holy cow it's already
been seven months
and since then i have come to terms with
the fact that
it's not my videos on architecture or
creativity
or portfolio tips or presentation tips
but it's actually my friggin macbook
review
that you guys seem to like the most you
know what that is okay with me
but if you're here and you haven't
checked out any of my other videos
i have a whole world of fun videos on
architecture and the design process that
are
much more interesting than this if you
haven't checked it out
please do a laptop is a tool after all
today i'm gonna be talking about my
thoughts on the m1
so far after using it for seven months
some of the things that i like
some things that i don't like as you
probably know when the m1 first came out
a lot of the architecture softwares were
not compatible yet
but we will go through the softwares
today
and i'll show you which ones work and
which ones don't work so well
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here my name is dani and i am
a licensed architect
in beautiful vancouver bc on this
channel we talk about architecture and
design
and also some tools and strategies that
can help us have more meaningful
and fulfilling careers in architecture
and today
we will be talking about the macbook air
i
use my m1 mostly for my personal
architecture projects
which are a lot smaller than the work
that i do in my office
and i also use it for my youtube channel
so
researching writing editing and all that
jazz
and for general browsing and online
shopping
for those uses i absolutely love the m1
i love how lightweight it is and the 15
hour battery life
like that is such a treat i can kind of
take it around
and not really have to worry about it
dying
or like looking for a plug it's kind of
exactly
as it's promoted it's silent it doesn't
have a fan
so even when i'm running some heavy duty
rendering programs it's not making any
sound especially when i'm doing video
recording or voice recording it's really
great because you don't hear
the sound of the computer at all and in
fact that's what i'm doing right now
also you can download any ios app on the
computer
which is pretty cool i do have a
separate dell laptop that's
provided by my office which is what i
use
for my bigger work project in the past
seven or so months a lot of apps
have become compatible with the m1 but
there's still
quite a few apps that are not a lot of
these apps still rely on rosetta for
compatibility
and i think it will take another couple
of months
if not a couple more years for all the
apps to be
fully optimized for apple silicon so
there's a lot of debate on whether
apple is going to start becoming more
popular in the architecture industry
but just based on my personal experience
all the firms that i've worked at we've
always used pc
and i think that's just because a lot of
the architecture softwares are
designed and optimized for pc
i think it'll be very very very unlikely
for a company to
take on the task of switching to mac os
just because that's a huge amount of
time and
energy i don't really see that happening
unless
we're 150 sure that all of the softwares
are going to be compatible
when you're working and you're doing
renderings or
anything that requires a lot of
processing power
you will want to connect your m1
to a power source because things like
that will
drain the battery a little bit faster
and so what that means is that you're
gonna have only
one usbc port left if you want to
connect to
another hard drive or another device
i've purchased a usbc hub so you can
have
a couple more ports for connecting to
multiple devices
including regular size type a ports
some of the hubs also come with a sd
card reader
and also an ethernet port
[Music]
some of the usb c hubs come with a usbc
port that will let you charge your
laptop at the same time
so that leaves your laptop with one
free usbc port that you can use to
connect to another device before you
buy your adapter just make sure double
check that it's compatible with the m1
i've had problems with adapters
i will leave the links to the adapters
that i'm using
down in the description but just please
make sure
after you purchase that it works with
your computer and if it doesn't just
take advantage of amazon's amazing
return policy
and return it if you are someone who
likes to use
the screen and a second monitor and a
third monitor
you are out of luck because it seems
like
the m1 so far only lets you connect
to one extra monitor there are some
workarounds to this problem if you
really really need to have your third
screen
which is you can buy a display link
docking station
which will let you have multiple
monitors
but this is a pricey solution
kind of up to your discretion whether
that's a worthwhile investment for you
or not
[Music]
one of the most annoying things that i
found is that
mac os still in 2021
doesn't fully support the ntfs file
system
so for hard drives that are formatted in
ntfs you can still
read it but you can't write on it so if
you
want to use the ntfs file system because
maybe you have a lot of hard drives that
you use on a daily basis that's already
formatted in ntfs there's two things you
can do
you can format your drive in the exfat
file system that's
cross-compatible between windows and mac
but
if you can't do that you can use a
software that lets you do that
for example the one that i'm using is
ntfs for mac
i'll leave the link to that below you
can format the drive
inside mac os but you will face the same
problem
if you want to connect that drive to a
windows platform
that's gonna be problematic if you're
working with someone who's using a pc
you need to share the files
in most cases that drive won't even show
up on your colleague's computer
that's just gonna add a huge amount of
friction to your workflow
so it's something you really need to be
very careful about
so something you have to put in the
budget when you're buying an
m1 is a good type c
hub and possibly a ntfs for mac
okay so now i'm just gonna switch over
to the architecture softwares and
show you which ones are compatible and
which ones are not
i know guys this is not like a
scientific
technically based review but you can
find all of the technical data
elsewhere um much better than i can
provide i just wanted to show you
a review based on my experience of using
these softwares okay so let's
first try sketchup
sketchup i have used on this computer
quite a bit
and it works perfectly it doesn't really
seem to have any glitches
but i will just show you
yeah so this is a
173 megabyte file pretty
pretty big file
but it runs fairly smoothly
don't really have any problems with it
yeah so this is actually a fairly
complex file um i have
a lot of blocks and
lots of different polygons and
i have texture maps on the surfaces
i have these
plant geometries it runs
pretty similar to my desktop
pc but you can see that
there is a little bit of a lag when
this is in real time you can see that
there is a little bit of a lag
with the texture mapping so i have a
texture applied on this surface
and on the ground but when i pan around
the texture kind of disappears
and it takes a couple of seconds for it
to
reappear there we go okay so let's go to
rhino
and so rhino i recently updated to their
new version
which seems to work quite well the
previous
version had some problems i would pan
around the model
and within a couple of seconds it would
have an
error and it would just crash and so it
seems like
they have solved that issue
and i'll just show you a heavier
file if there's any lags
so this one is a 270
megabyte file and
when i was using my um heavy duty
gamer desktop in the cat lab this
file was liking significantly but
on this it's running very very smoothly
and i'm very happy about that
yeah really no issues kind of
panning around so yeah with the
renderings typically with my workflow i
don't really do
renders with my work computer i do do
like video renderings but
with architectural renderings i usually
do it in my
work desktop so i haven't really tried
it on this computer
but probably for my next video
just because there has been quite a lot
of requests about
testing the um rendering abilities on
this computer
i will probably test out enscape
twin motion and v-ray on this computer
if you guys want me to test out any
other rendering softwares just let me
know
so vectorworks does seem like it's been
optimized to run
on the m1 i haven't really found any
issues so far
just panning around it
[Music]
okay so now let's try archicad
um i have downloaded a
couple of their models uh their sample
project
from their website and they had a pretty
good variety of models of different
sizes
they had ones from 340 megabytes
to uh 660 megabytes
so uh why don't we try opening up the
small one first
yeah here is the axo of the model
so yeah this is yeah i've actually never
used archicad before
um i got my m1 and i've just been
playing around with it recently and i
really like it um
it's actually quite a lot like the
interface is quite a lot nicer than
revit
revit has this very like construction
documenty look to it
but i find that archicad just produces
nicer looking
cleaner looking drawings and
the 3d is much much
much smoother to pan around and walk
around
so i do i do quite like that a lot
um yeah for example just moving around
the model like this
in revit um it i i
it would take me a little longer for the
model to load
as i walk around and
in revit it's more like um
[Music]
like i typically just set up the views
for
the areas that i want to look at and
then i
click from one view to another
and i rarely kind of pan around the
model
like this if i wanted to do something
like this i would open up enscape
and kind of move around the model like
that
but yeah i just really like how
smooth the 3d views
of archicad is yeah it's really nice i
like it a lot
okay and then let's do autocad autocad
is a industry standard and
most firms use autocad on a daily basis
i have heard of people saying that they
were having problems accessing the
toolbox
but i have not experienced that
in my computer it does seem to run
quite smoothly and
i mean autocad has always had a
mac version and so i don't think that
compatibility with m1 was too
difficult of a transition but yeah
there and also autocad is a much simpler
a much lighter software than um
something like revit or archicad so okay
so now let's move on to revit which
for me is the critical software
revit is the tool that i've used
in all of my years working in
architecture all the firms that i've
worked at has used revit
so revit does not run natively
on the mac os so you do have to run
uh parallel software some of you may
have heard
um they just recently introduced
parallel
um a couple months ago you can open up
a parallel pc desktop on
the m1 and so i went ahead and
downloaded
revit 2022
and there we go
a crash error report the software has
cost revit 2022 to close
unexpectedly we apologize for the
inconvenience
an unrecoverable error has occurred the
program will now be terminated
all of your data has been recently saved
so there's no blah
so this has been happening consistently
every single time i try to open revit on
parallels and so my
take on this is that revit
actually doesn't work on the m1 i
haven't really found any resources
online
to explain why this is happening
but i will report
back and let you guys know if there are
any updates to this
but so far it seems like revit does not
work on the m1 which is a shame
so that was the end of the video i hope
you guys found that fairly helpful
i definitely love using this laptop but
it is my secondary laptop i have my pc
as my primary laptop for doing all my
architecture work
this i reserve for doing my youtube
videos
my editing and more of my general use
would i recommend this as a primary
laptop if you're an architect probably
not
because it's not ready as you saw revit
did not
function properly on this computer but
if you are someone who doesn't use revit
at
all if you are someone who doesn't think
that
you will ever work for a firm that will
use revit
then yeah it could be a great option for
you
everything that i talked about in this
video you should definitely
take into consideration before making
this investment with all that being said
that's
kind of it i will follow up in the next
video
where i test out some of the rendering
softwares on this computer if you
found this video helpful please give me
a thumbs up check out some of my other
videos i have
videos on architecture and design and
the design process
that could be a little bit more
interesting than this one otherwise i
will see you guys in the next video
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you